and you're back Hillary Clinton's the
devil is something we always suspected
WikiLeaks just confirmed it with the
release of dozens of thousands of emails
with WikiLeaks it's kind of like
drinking from a firehose for a lot of
people that's hard to navigate
especially because the media doesn't
want you to even try it's illegal to
possess these stolen documents it's
different for the media so everything
you learn about this you're learning
from us thanks for looking out CN n some
of the wiki leaks are incredibly damning
Lee they would be if we weren't
desensitized to the corruption of our
current political system but there are
some stories out there that aren't even
real from WikiLeaks they're made up for
example Hillary Clinton's body was not
snatched nor replaced with number five
from short-circuit though it is
plausible something to remember with all
the tabloid headlines out there a
personal testimony is one of the least
reliable forms of evidence in court one
of the most reliable documents hard
evidence which is why WikiLeaks is so
important these are hacked emails most
of which you'll see today come from John
Podesta chairman for the 2016 Hillary
campaign and a former chief of staff to
mr. president Bill Clinton and counselor
to one mr. President Barack Obama top
ten WikiLeaks you need to know let's get
to it
starting off with a bang number one
Hillary Clinton wants open borders in a
transcript taken from a speech Hillary
Clinton said my dream is a hemispheric
common market with open trade and open
borders so this is problematic to use
their term only if you believe in
countries the term globalism is thrown
around so flippantly today it's lost all
meaning but the term globalism
what's infected for this
number two admission that the Iran deal
was absolutely horrible as we said it
was written from John Anzalone this
agreement condemns the next generation
to cleaning up a nuclear war in the
Persian Gulf this is the greatest
appeasement since Chamberlain cave
Czechoslovakia to Hitler to which one
mr. John Podesta
replied yep he don't even fight it the
entire DNC in the public eye no no the
Iran deal isn't what you think behind
closed doors it's exactly what you think
it sucks
thanks Satan number three for all you
basement dwellers out there the
manipulation and/or possible bribing of
Bernie Sanders written to John Podesta
we are going to need his voters to
turnout in November for Hillary Rodham
Clinton he won't be nominated I am doing
the opposite repeatedly writing friendly
and positive pieces about Bernie as a
Hillary supporter and when the time is
right I will have money in the bank with
him and his people as a liberal to urge
them to come out in force to vote for
Hillary Rodham Clinton we get it Bernie
Sanders got a raw deal from the DNC but
he was above it all except he's got
three houses to pay for dollar dollar
bills y'all
number four Democrats created fake
sexist Trump ads are you smelling
desperation yet some of the job
requirements designed to look as an ad
to work for Trump
we're as follows no gaining weight on
the job must be open to public
humiliation a willingness to evaluate
other women's hotness proficient and
lying about age if the boss thinks
you're too old firstly I don't have too
many gripes with those but we know that
a lot of women would and that's the
point slander and impersonation coming
directly from the horse's mouth don't
call them horses that's also sexist but
some of them look like horses believe me
when I tell you
[Music]
[Laughter]
number five which is particularly timely
because right now the current Democratic
Party's being accused of committing
voter fraud which they deny which is
interesting because Hillary Clinton in
her campaign vehemently accused Barack
Obama of committing voter fraud in
Colorado I met with Jim and Mike in
Denver they are both old friends of the
Clintons and have lots of experience
Mike hosted our Boulder Roadshow event
they're reliving the Oh eight caucuses
where they believe the Obama forces
flooded the caucuses with ineligible
voters they want to organize lawyers for
caucus protection election protection
and to raise hard cash symbol one thing
you'll find remarkably consistent is the
typos and emojis in these emails it
worse is slightly grating but worth
noting again publicly Democrats deny
deny deny that they commit voter fraud
behind closed doors when there's the
infighting and they know that we're not
watching they know of course that voter
fraud is being committed but welcome to
hell number six you know how we always
talk about how the Left refuses to say
Islamic terrorism and it almost seems
like they have their fingers crossed
hoping that every next mass shooter or
terrorist is white and they say no no no
no well it turns out they do as written
in a private email from again Podesta
better if a guy named Syed Farook was
reporting that a guy named Christopher
Hayes was the shooter yes clearly that
would have been better for your campaign
not so much America and that's the
overarching theme here what's good for
Hillary not so much good for America
what's good for the goose is good for
the gander they just kill all the geese
number seven and eight are kind of
joined we could probably have another 20
30 45 thousand of these examples of the
Democratic Party and media collusion but
of course it wouldn't have time for that
list so the two that stand out to me
most are CNN's Donna Brazile gave the
Clintons a heads up regarding a Bernie
tweet storm how do I know
well because Podesta wrote thanks for
the heads-up on this Donna call it a
detective's intuition and yet again more
proof that Bernie got a raw deal not a
huge Bernie fan but boy did he get
screwed on this the next one is our own
resident favorite Ezra Klein of voxcom
if you watch our show at all you know
that we have a good laugh about Vox
a--'s articles nearly every week and
we've rebutted a few of their videos
particularly on gun control as a matter
of fact they are so known to be
misleading in far-left
there's a verb an urban dictionary Vox
splaining is what they do
of course they deny deny deny deny deny
but when asked with who they thought
would keep other journalists accountable
namely only printing positive stories
about Hillary Clinton Jennifer Palmieri
palmi Airy I don't know wrote this I
think that person the degree to which
they exist is as recline and we can do
it with him today so you've got Donna
Brazile teaming up with the Clintons
teaming up with Ezra Klein and of course
CNN telling you don't read these emails
we'll read them for you are you noticing
a trend if not you you might be a stupid
person number nine this is important we
know from WikiLeaks that Hillary Clinton
knowingly criminally deleted emails
leave it again publicly deny deny deny
but we see in a private email exchange
with her staffers okay one thing to use
personal email but why the twisted truth
on why with the to problematic areas
being emails to Bill when they were to
build staff and be only using one device
I can't really read that the typos are
awful blackberry when two weeks earlier
it was an iPhone Blackberry an iPad as
Anne and I discussed hopefully that's a
timing issue in Wellston State she only
used one quick pause you know this is
authentic because they use the word
problematic continue I know when I
talked to my friends who are attorneys
we are all struggling with what happened
to the emails and aren't satisfied with
ants
to date while we all know the occasional
use of personal email addresses for
business none of my friends circle can
understand how it was viewed as okay
secure appropriate to use a private
server for secure documents and why
further Hilary took it upon herself to
review them and delete documents without
providing anyone outside her circle a
chance to weigh in it smacks of acting
above the law it smacks of the type of
thing I've either gotten discovery
sanctions for fired people for etc I
don't know that I can add much more so
let's go to number 10 that President
Barack Obama and Hillary Clinton
correspondent
via private email why is this so
important she knowingly deleted emails
as you see in those exchanges why would
she let go when it is illegal to do that
a lot of people suspected that this may
go to the top it may reflect poorly on
President Barack Obama otherwise why
would he protect her from the fall
there's a lot of back-and-forth here's a
highlight National Review talked about
it in an email from Podesta to Mills
he said think we should hold emails to
and from the president that's the heart
of his executive privilege we could get
them to ask for that they may not care
but it seems like they will in other
words they put these emails under a
special category where only Barack Obama
would have the executive privilege to
ask for them or release them you think
Barack Obama was going to do that no of
course not it reflected poorly on him
and Hillary and she could drag the ship
down with her
people the emails verifiably prove
beyond any shadow of a doubt that
Hillary Clinton is lying Barack Obama
himself has been lying and the media has
been lying all along with them and
they've been laughing about it through
private emails the whole way now I know
we could look silly because at the time
of this video they're still releasing
more and it could get a whole lot worse
I suspect that it will hopefully they
bring this up in this week's debate
we'll be live-streaming it you don't
need a conspiracy you don't need a lie
you don't need to blow up something any
bigger than it is just go read the
WikiLeaks emails and understand that
it's already really bad if nothing else
a silver lining in this election is I
think a lot of people left or right
their eyes have been opened to just how
easily they've been manipulated and how
proactive the media has been in doing
that you don't need to trust them
anymore
they don't need to be the gatekeepers
anymore because you know they've been
lying to you the greatest trick the
devil ever pulled was convincing the
world he didn't exist time you're still
here that means you have some decisions
to make go to ladder with Crowder comm
for references click my face to
subscribe watch one of these videos next
to me or you can click the mystery box
now I'm not gonna lie to you
mystery box land can get weird and by
weird I mean the kind of weird you don't
come back from or sometimes it can be
wonderful but a lot of the times it's
weird